[Musique]
le centre de recherche en neurosciences
de lyon cherche des personnes
frange le site d'un déficit de
perception musicale
pour le dire clairement vous sentez
complètement faux ouais mais vous ne
vous en rendez pas compte et les
chercheurs veulent comprendre ce qui
cloche dans votre cerveau les cobayes
seront même rémunérés bref être payé
pour hurler des fausses notes
on ne citera pas de noms mais reconnaît
des chanteuses au des chanteurs comme on
fait un métier blaye tout un acte j'ai
pas le taï do le moteur numéro moi je
vis de sky avec mes bébés autres des
pansements jean herrero j'arrive dans le
club et l'ambiance est au taquet
tu me fais rire c'est début des vacances
et je disais pourquoi tu me fais rire
faut que parce que c'est le début des
vacances que parfois nous partons en
vacances les gens là ça c'est vrai et
aux sommes partis en vacances et je t'ai
dit bonnes vacances et ayant répondu
excuse moi mais moi j'ai du pain sur la
planche c'est vrai regarde ta couleur
c'est vrai regarde comment tu aies
croisé l'énoncé ta télé qui malgré ses
bien sûr et vous avez des enfants
j'ai quatre enfants et sa marque cartier
ils sont dans le quartier une au collège
dans les gares ni la jda est une qui
gémit à saint jean de védas pour
justement peu plus de mixité pouvoir
parce que c'est vrai qu'on manque de
maîtrise dans ici c'est vraiment un
problème ici et d'un quartier populaire
j'ai appris à être fière
bien plus d'amour que
bien plus de coeur que de pierre g
présidence j'ai mon fils qui a 8 ans il
m'a demandé si pied l'entraînement de
pierre existait vraiment c'est que dans
le livre
tellement qu'ils aiment manque de mixité
dans le quartier c'est vraiment grave
quoi je lui ai dit non au fils pierre et
distrait mans il ya des gens qui
s'appellent pierre
moi je fais sortir mes enfants mais
c'est vrai que cette question m'a pas
choqué quand j'entends ça parce que là
je le dois le dire c'est une grande
première je crois en 20 ans des missions
je me dois de faire le cri du corbeau
voilà sinon qu'est-ce que je pourrais
tenir votre tu as des questions pascal
caumont qui pose des questions je vais
pas faire le kgb mais bon ça n'existe
plus donc les tranquilles non
[Rires]
ok ok voilà le disque ans et plus joseba
qu'est ce que je veux dire
allez c'est pas moi c'est pas lourd
c'est dans la tête allez prends trois
fleurs et pourquoi ça gagnant gagnant
dépêche-toi ils sont des millions sur
weibo le réseau social chinois avoir
commenté cette vidéo celle d'une
employée frappant violemment et à
plusieurs reprises son patron à coup de
serpillière la raison ce patron l'a
harcelé en lui envoyant des textos à
caractère sexuel madame joue la victime
a reçu un immense soutien populaire
les affaires de harcèlement débouchant
très peu devant la justice en chine
saleh retrouve carrément tu es vraiment
attentionné seront ouais c'est ton
premier petit déjeuner en tant que femme
on n'en attendait hier matin des côtes
et le temps passe si vite et donc en
fait nous on en a profité également pour
faire notre mariage de noces et donc
nous sommes mariage de noces oui alors
votre nuit de noce votre mariage c'est
quoi un maillage de notre voyage de
noces pdg s'est en fait c'est un jeu il
faut retrouve la phrase avec les mots
qui sont dans la phrase c'est quand même
une entrée remarquable
madame cendrillon dont vous allez vous
madame la comtesse sérieux que deux
choses ça doit bien mais par contre pour
moi il faut absolument 300 chevaux genre
300 chevaux gros bolides je veux qu'on
entende le moteur turbo jardin vous
savez classe voilà tu attendais
tu vas tu as peur du dragon j'ai trop
poussé
ce qui est bien c'est que vous buvez vos
propres olive vous sentez vos propres
aux biens mais ce nom mais c'est
important
c'est bien j'adore ce genre de
dispositif c'est un plaisir de sentir
ses preuves grâce aux livres non et non
seulement ne vous sert cette souplesse
prix voilà si tu serais dans une déserte
et aux rémois est un genre à l'animal et
les notables et tu dois avoir un comme
une sorte d'animal un saint jacques des
puces et genre tu dois avoir une
relation ça c'est avec ce message où
l'animal avec moi un messi qui dont les
tâches du dessus est tombé c'est vrai
que c'est dur
horrible ça veut dire qui a perdu les
personnes à l'étagé du dessus dans
l'arbre généalogique hiller phelim
horrible a fait horrible comme
définition c'est gai c'est lundi bonnes
semaines encore
[Musique]
tu margot suis pas contre mais c'est pas
grave ça va vous ça va mieux ça va
beaucoup mieux
quelques courbatures après j'ai perdu le
goût l'odorat c'était très très
compliqué je confondais le jour la nuit
et a été nulle savage
je suis plein d'anticorps ça va bien je
ne me fais plus vaccinée pour l'instant
donc florian philippot non je pas été
vaccinés vous allez vous faire vacciner
c'est pas prévu non pas des questions
pièges vous donne un astrazeneca bon ça
sent pas astra zeneca wyeth est vécue au
danemark je suis l'autorité danoise
qu'il l'a interdit quand vous signale
qu'il est pas autorisée à cet effet le
marabout ouais je ne savais pas comme le
salut de celui-ci
je viens aussi d'ailleurs la suède parce
que j'en ai profité bon il ya peu tout
seul à mettre deux mois et qui va
raconter pour faire le test dans mail et
la wii va nous manger tous les jours
mais alors les gens préfèrent se faire
tester
oui pratiquement de rien parce que tout
se négocie à partir du nikkei et à un
nom de feu merci merci non faites vous
la clé qu'est ce que c'est un mot retour
et je sais qu'à points bien précis on
doit mourir on doit mourir un jour 14 et
le 17
voilà trois quarts d'heure les thèmes se
mêlent 17 mai on se retrouve dans toute
la france selon météo france partout en
france quinze jours après ouverture à
moins qu'ils aient quoi lauriers dit non
alors quinze jours après ouverture de
l'intérêt avec une jauge à 50%
et quand un jour après on redit tous
normalement